cambiamos de posición un drone nos
identificó y nos bombardeó qué colores
cuidamos de los heridos y mientras se
evacuaba a uno de mis compañeros fue
golpeado y
víctor de 28 años es parte de las
fuerzas especiales de ucrania en mayo
seguridad sufrió grandes pérdidas
luego tuvimos nueve nidos dos muertos y
cinco sufrieron heridas cerebrales
graves
y luego el concurso no puedo decir que
sufro por las imágenes que vi
psicológicamente estoy bien es sólo que
me siento inútil
al igual que víctor la mayoría de los
200 pacientes de este hospital son
soldados heridos en combate
luego de ser estabilizados permanecen
allí por un promedio de tres semanas
originalmente la misión de la
institución era ayudar a los veteranos
de donbass a reintegrarse a la vida
civil
nuestro objetivo principal es ayudar a
los combatientes a recuperarse de
lesiones y traumas expone y así ayudamos
a que el mayor número posible de
soldados vuelva a sus actividades y a su
servicio
esas son nuestras prioridades debemos
prepararlos físicamente y darles la
fuerza moral para ir a la guerra
nuevamente tras el esfuerzo ser joven ha
sido tanto el marzo de este año
alexander participó en una batalla
violenta con tanques e infantería en la
región de done jets que fue herido en la
pierna
aunque no descarta volver al frente esa
perspectiva aún es lejana
inmediatamente después de la explosión
estuve en un muy mal estado tartamudeaba
pero esto ya ha mejorado
mi sueño aún no está afectado me
despierto varias veces por la noche
porque no puedo respirar tengo
pesadillas que dicen mejor cadera
sueño que me sobre vuelan aviones
me despierto asustado y sonando
físicamente creo que me puedo recuperar
pero psicológicamente no estoy seguro en
este hospital especializado en estrés
postraumático la relajación y la
acupuntura son parte del programa los
especialistas están atentos a los
detalles de los choques neurológicos
consecuencia de los combates
primero tratamos muchas lesiones
cerebrales porque es una guerra de
artillería
estas las llamamos heridas invisibles de
hierba
en segundo lugar no es normal que la
psiquis humana participe en una acción
militar
por lo general comienzan a ver todo en
blanco y negro
es muy común para este tipo de soldados
ellos ya no perciben los matices del
mundo
orientarse es más complicado para los
civiles que están inmersos en el
conflicto
[Música]
al inicio de la guerra o el éxito de 26
años se alistó para la defensa
territorial
su tratamiento incluye sesiones de
tienes estimulación magnética
transcraneal
lo que muestra en la gc
la estimulación magnética transcraneal
se usa para tratar la ansiedad
la depresión y la tartamudez inducida
por trauma
no tenía experiencia militar pero estaba
preparado físicamente
practicaba artes marciales defensa
personal
[Música]
álex y fue desplegado rápidamente en una
unidad de reconocimiento bajo mando
militar y llegó a la primera línea
cuando hay tormenta el agua no para de
caer
era lo mismo con los misiles y los
cohetes pasó muy bien sea divertido
mi misión era evacuar a la gente
[Música]
y después descubrí que tenía una bomba
psicológica
y decidí tomar un respiro hacerme un
largo y
estoy feliz de ser completamente
funcional tras grabar el recurso de
caminar comer o ir y respirar
es una oportunidad de volver con vida no
tengo la oportunidad de vivir amar y
trabajar
porque es aprovechar esta oportunidad
para seguir adelante en dos periodos